Plays a circuit.
So there's a guy named Jaak,
Panksepp,
who I would roundly recommend that you read if you're interested in in
behavioral neuroscience.
I think he's a genius.
He's sort of on par with gray as far as I'm concerned.
And on par with Swanson and peg,
except I believe discovered the play circuit in mammals.
And so,
you know,
two thumbs up for him.
That's a big deal.
That's kind of like discovering a continent from the psychological perspective.
And it's a search,
it's a circuit that separate from exploration,
which is kind of interesting cause you think about play as a form of exploratory
behavior,
but it's sufficiently different from,
from standard exploratory behavior that it has a circuit that's devoted to it.
And there's a lot of primary circuits,
you know,
and they're networked in with the rest of the brain.
And obviously circuit is a,
you know,
a metaphor.
So I could say there's a lot of primary subpersonalities,
they're like one eyed monster.
There's only one thing thereafter,
you know,
and there's a whole bunch of them.
And so roughly speaking,
they regulate the things I already mentioned that the hypothalamus regulates
defensive aggression,
sexual behavior,
temperature,
regulation,
food and water intake,
excretion,
while then there's one for breathing,
then there's another for pain,
then there's another for anxiety.
Um,
and there's another for exploration and there's others.
There's sensory modules as well.
You know,
there's a visual circuit and an auditory circuit and the olfactory circuit and
the circuit that's devoted to taste and,
and there's a circuit that keeps track of how your body is localized in space.
That's a parietal circuit.
And um,
what else is important?
Oh yeah.
There's a circuit that you can use to abstractly model perceptual structures and
patterns of behavior before you implement them in the world.
And that seems to be a higher cortical function fundamentally.
And you'd associate that with the contents of your consciousness.
There's a language circuit,
um,
though.
Oh yeah.
There's an empathy circuit that mediates maternal behavior.
There's a hunting circuit that mediates predatory behavior.
There's a circuit to check dominance and subordinate subordination.
MMM.
There's a circuit that mediates creativity and human beings.
There's a circuit that mediates social activity.
So,
and,
and the,
the positive reinforcing nature of social activity.
And that's quite tightly expo x associated with the exploratory circuit.
Um,
let's see.
Well that's,
you know,
that's not too bad for the beginning.
I'm sure I've missed some and I'll remember them.
But,
and each of those subsystems is important enough so that there's a neuro
architecture devoted to it.
Now some of those neural architectures are flexible enough so that if they don't
develop one brain area,
they'll develop an another.
So it's,
it's not exactly as if the location of these functions is specifically
determined in advance before development.
So for example,
if you have a baby and it has,
you know,
epilepsy and the epilepsy is really bad,
sometimes they'll take out the whole left or right hemisphere.
And if they do that early enough doesn't really seem to have much consequence
for the baby,
you know,
which is pretty weird.
You think?
Well,
half the brain that problem fairly useful.
But in some sense it's as if the cortical elements of the brain are territory
that can be inhabited in colonized by the lower levels of the brain.
And so you could say that the lower levels of the brain,
including the visual input systems,
would just as soon call a nice,
what we call the visual cortex.
But if there's no visual cortex because it's being removed,
then they'll just go call tonight as part of the auditory cortex.
You know,
and what you see in other situations sometimes is that people have high,
high hydrocephaly.
And what that means is that their cerebral spinal fluid builds up in their
brain.
And so the ventricles get very enlarged.
And so if you take an x ray or an MRI or other sort of scan,
if these people,
you'll find that their entire skull is full of water except for like a half inch
thin slice of cortical tissue around the water,
like a balloon.
And one of the guys who was like that,
they had a phd in mathematics from Cambridge,
you know,
5% of his brain tissue is intact.
Now,
it was pretty active that 5% and you could also be sure that it would not have
been very resilient to damage.